i'm here with comedian nikki glazer
and her mom julie and they've been
quarantining together
oh my god oh my god you both are so
beautiful oh my gosh
thank you so much i know i i post
pictures of her as much as i can on
instagram just to show men that might be
interested in me like look what
look what's in the future that's
adorable i'm not kidding
nikki i was thinking i was like oh my
god i wonder when my daughters are your
age like
you know i i assume i'm going to look
like the crypt keeper and i
you know not because i'm beating up on
myself aesthetically i'm just going to
be
you know they're going to be so proud oh
my gosh
thank you julie goals um
so i know you guys have been corning
quarantined together for a while so if
it's okay i thought we could play a
little
newlywed style game with you guys oh i
can't wait yeah
awesome oh my god mothers and daughters
is my whole life this is so fun
um okay start with you julie what's
nikki's favorite thing
to spend money on um
without a doubt i would say starbucks
oh yeah she's a freak of starbucks
that's embarrassing but it's true
it's so true i'm addicted yeah several
times a day
i feel a gift card coming on nikki
what's your mom's biggest pet peeve
about you
um that i'm really really messy and uh
since living at home
she thought maybe i would have like
improved since high school but i haven't
my room is in the same uh tornadic state
that it
it's always been in i haven't learned
you really haven't
no it's okay julie when you guys have a
fight
who is the first to kind of put it back
together
i would say me oh
i mean i feel like it is but um
she would say differently i feel like i
taught you how to apologize and you've
just gotten really good at it and now
you're showing off lately but yeah i
mean yeah
you have taught me something i have i
had to be like do you know what an
apology is it's when you say
i'm sorry and you don't add a butt to it
yeah but i
i apologize when i don't even do
anything wrong that's true
i'm just mom that's how hard i'm doing
i'm sorry i saw this question
nate goes first rate your mom's cooking
on a scale from one to ten um
okay i will say a solid
i'll do an eight because there's room
for improvement but
um but it's yeah you you nail it most of
the time
i think i do yeah you're that's oh and
eight is amazing my kids would give me
like a one
um okay um julie
if you could create the perfect husband
for your daughter what would he be like
well probably like her father for sure
oh my god sorry nikki i mean i don't
want to marry your dad i know but
most girls look for someone like their
father it's true
it's just the way it came from yeah he's
a great guy so that's nice
yeah i think that's the good answer she
loves her father yeah
and nikki what is one thing you want to
make sure
your mom knows about the way you feel
about her oh that's so nice thank you
for this opportunity because
it's all it's hard to say this not on
camera
or like when there's like an audience
it's easier for me to be sincere
with an audience than like one-on-one
but i would just say that like
you're incredible you're beautiful i i
wish you would saw yourself the way i
see you
and i wish you felt the way about
yourself that i feel about you
and i know you feel the same way about
me so um and
i just hope to be as i just hoped to
turn into you if i could sign up a
document that said i was gonna be
exactly like you when i was your age i
would do it in a heartbeat i've never
heard anything like that that's so
really sweet well i can't say this stuff
what would you put on nikki's
dating apps if she wasn't allowed to
write it for herself
oh mom what would you put on my dating
app um
that i have the best heart
oh yeah you can cardiovascular yes
you're strong
you've got a strong heart thank you no
she's got the best heart
in the world oh she just does i am
i can't thank you guys enough for
playing this game with me and
i my daughter once um did this thing for
my birthday where she filled out a
questionnaire of blanks
and i put it in a frame and
i i look at it all the time and i just i
love mothers and daughters you guys are
so awesome
i just i really nikki i'm not that kind
of person and this isn't that kind of
show where it's like thank you it was so
nice to have you on will you you know
see you around
like will you come back can we hang out
and do fun things on the show i would do
something on the news with you i would
do a comedy sketch with you i would do
stand-up with you
i would i would i would do anything
sometimes yes
dating apps and mothers and daughters
and everything
i'll get your starbucks for you drew
i'll do anything i'll get your starbucks
for you
nikki julie thank you i love you guys so
much thank you so much for coming on the
show
okay you're perfect exactly by the way
i'd pick you over any guy any day